hello and welcome to this video porque
know if that is pronounced correctly
that's a new opponent is that new
account smell oh it's a brand new
account ok and it's currently operating
on his all-time high so let's see what
we get ready gambit ok be sure to form
it's not a bad line they followed up
with bishop e6 and this is on a tad
critical for black we'll see what
happens there are idea this g4 and age
for here i can start with g4 or play the
check first I'm always kind of unsure
check what to do first I think it's not
a big difference I'm starting with the
chick oh it's going back with this ok
it's kind of interesting i wonder if i
can still go g4 h4 i think i'm going to
try
don't quite see why it shouldn't work
funny way of playing here's some this
exactly this idea ok well the usual
replies night takes f7 I just wonder if
there is a particular reason why that
wouldn't work here so night f7 Bishop f4
9088 the bishop is hanging like an odd
so take on b7 so it does work it should
even be a little bit better than usual
because usually there is a knight on f6
and the other night on d 7 so black can
pick up g for at the end so this should
be quite good for wide so I wanna pawn
him Knight takes d5 is quite often
possible in such a position it's not
necessary that we can also play yeah
quote unquote normal moose let's see do
a cool 95 it's a little bit different to
some other positions i also have g4
plata this is something that I have to
take take into account so how to do this
94 I think isn't isn't such a big deal
you will probably play some Queen h4
later still what is my setup here III d
for I guess ok there's night before ever
go III so that's probably quite a stupid
move in general the Queen seems a little
bit a little bit problematic on C toon
ok I think I'm going to return it
okay so this is a tacked-on geofoam I
wanted to go here but 295 is actually
double attacking so I have to cover it
with a ch3 a little bit behind him
time-wise 95 or night before I cannot
answer with deform III d 4 was what I
wanted to play anyway so I'm kind of
okay with this so here I can move the
king but then I'll cancel I am so I'll
cancel now this this was the setup that
I had in mind when i started with 21 age
three and so on it looks quite safe and
I'm keeping my pawn no this is a fairly
safe position I don't see him breaking
through with a five and this would be
the only thing that would that would
really be a quite a concern will seem
not happy that I have to play be three
but Nazi forces on the annoying side and
don't want to see that so here what's
going on is he trying to sacrifice on
deform it's possible I wasn't quite sure
about the knight on c3 anyway so it
could be new could be a good idea might
be a good idea to put it on f3 for
example
okay I don't mind if you if we trade
this okay so III now we should be toast
not all that not all that silly but
night before is entertaining so I'll go
83 I wonder if he is so I added since a
good move attending a 4mm and then get
night see foreign yeah that's good it's
a good move so how do i play this i can
group b 1 maybe so that a for i can take
Queen g6 is going to double the area it
seems
my against Nazi 40 interesting ok
yeah as I said I'm not entirely happy
here with the queenside being a cheeky
but I have some active ideas myself not
okay try I'm morning yay i'm going to go
for you for him you for currently a
little bit tricky if i take the Queen
boat egg so I have to have to cover this
and I have to speed up which is rather
important so I want to go E for here
which should yeah that's good I need to
get this going here some initiative if
you take that ninety XY position is
excellent i think unless there is a
tactic okay so f five will be coming
queen bee three days Roxy 302 trade
stuff here six h4 h5 okay how to do this
like this
last one will be three know so tough
business in
it doesn't look old that doesn't look
Jack it's not according to the rules and
then 16 seconds oh my god I spoiled a
great position here actually check white
forfeits on time oh wow that's
embarrassing should really win this game
so maybe f6 was too slow when it's
really possible by 92 is completely
winning with neither for coming because
he's completely overloaded down yeah
that's a lot stronger yeah John I think
I saw that good control with this um he
had we in the air after opening here it
is still light slightly tricky white um
yeah and some kind of let's say
correspondence chess or something what
is just enormously better but it's it's
a little bit unconventional the position
so things can happen but I think this is
just very very good for wide so I'm
happy with this engine confirms that i
was taking but taking a bit too long I
mean first game over session tends to be
tricky I was taking even more time than
usual ya hear all this is basically ok
you can improve on it but it's still a
position that is close to winning four
wide f5 now is strong but what I think
what I'd it isn't all that bad I mean
here I got in deform and it's just it's
just basically um and very nice for wide
yeah I teach was a lot stronger or
taking only six ninety two day after
night
he cannot cover this and he takes ages
with the bleep on the promise what I did
is probably not bad in itself I mean but
it just takes a long while until
something materializes and he has this
simple plan offices pushing the beer
pong and by now it's it gets dangerous
right okay this is stupid i should go
here went to try to take over there this
is still winning there with 92 wherefore
he gets he gets overloaded down but okay
I 30 seconds but no it was really not
easy at all I lost the temple basically
with this with this business and then
send yeah I'm losing with ruby three
this actually I can go we should be six
and then Queen takes be three a group
III was winning with 93 coming yeah by
now he is winning it is just easy to
push jump on mmm yeah I played that
badly then mostly had to spend too much
time here this is really a lot stronger
a lot stronger and he takes like one two
three it takes a lot of moves until it
gets dangerous and with 92 F for it just
collapses quite quickly so this beep on
doesn't really matter if you let's say
he goes b5 and I go here and I'm
threatening 90 x e6 and you cannot
capture here this is going to going to
be absolutely devastating so this is a
lot stronger just regroup the the night
down and here well this is I'm still
quicker here probably but it's something
that requires real precision this was a
lot better I'm not sure why I choose
that instead of just going there
immediately I mean I was thinking about
the H file somewhat but
now this is this is to a very good for
wine but it's of course by now tricky
and he has the has that pawn the engine
gives us nine check check and wide wins
but hmm that this is already very very I
mean it's dicey yeah you can can easily
imagine why it's screwing this up I mean
it's a it's what is that + 1.5 or
something but it's kind of tricky and
with 92 F for um yeah it would have been
would have been quite simple because it
doesn't have all that counter play those
nights don't defend the Kings side now
okay well I have to play a couple of
games to get back into begging destroyed
okay thanks for watching